[Music]
well as ted has been alerting us
each and every day allergy suffers
dealing with high counts of mulberry
ash and elm right now our spring winds
certainly don't help much either because
they spread the pollen
but if you think you leave it all
outdoors when you head inside your home
you're wrong we don't realize that
um allergies come inside with us so if
i've picked up pollen and i'm
i'm collecting it the dust and the and
the
invisible pollens on my clothes i'm
going to bring those inside so take your
shoes off change your clothes especially
if you're somebody who's sensitive
dr kathleen winston dean for the college
of nursing for the university of phoenix
says every season make sure your
ventilation system is working properly
change out those filters wash your hair
change out that pillowcase as well
now she says that over the counter
saline
nasal spray certainly helps keep your
nasal passages moist that helps
and just because you didn't have
allergies at one point in your life
doesn't mean you are immune
i do know that there are people out
there who pride themselves on you know
well i don't have any allergies so my
husband has lots of allergies
and um then suddenly they too begin to
experience that and they
they're they're unfamiliar or an older
adult i i know many times an older adult
will say you know i didn't have
allergies as a child
i wasn't one of those kids that um they
were worried about making sure i didn't
develop asthma because of my allergies
but um all of a sudden i'm finding i
have runny nose and i have
sinus complaints the good news of course
when the heat comes which isn't too far
from now seasonal allergy sufferers
won't have to worry again
until the fall